and hurricane durian may be spinning in
place but it is also widening and
tropical storm-force winds are reaching
parts of Florida including Juno Beach
Janet shamlian is there that's about a
hundred miles south of us and Janet
what's the weather like there now Nora
good morning it's a wet and windy one
here on the beach tropical storm-force
winds in fact gusts exceeding 60 miles
an hour at this location within the past
few hours with that storm stalled a
hundred miles off the coast this area is
just waiting to see what durian will do
this morning all Palm Beach County
schools are closed through Thursday the
airport is closed and at least three
hospitals in this area have shut their
doors transferring their patients to
other facilities there is a mandatory
evacuation order in effect many people
are heating that there are 11 shelters
in Palm Beach County set up 2,600 people
have gone to those shelters as of this
morning and officials are warning people
not to let their guard down with the
path of this storm still also uncertain
it is the end of a long holiday weekend
but it sure doesn't feel like it on this
stretch of the Florida coast
stores businesses restaurants all closed
in fact it's hard to find anything open
and Nora I wonder just want to show you
and talk a little bit about the erosion
here on the beach we were here yesterday
for CBS this morning and the surf and
the high waves have just washed away so
much of the sand it's very dramatic
having seen it just a day before Nora
Thank You Janet it's hard to find
anything open around here - and you're
right officials warning do not let your
guard down